serge fiori rêvait depuis plusieurs
années de faire de longues entrevues
avec certains de ses amis le rêve est
devenu réalité avec le projet j'ai pas
de riz avec serge fiori ça s'envole de
11 places à la corde grandes personnes
d'après leurs parcours leurs
intérêts ces fantasmes ou sortent
surtout s'ils ont trop bu l'eau en
bouleversant
et étrangers surtout travail ou t1 pour
ses émissions disponibles sur le web le
cofondateur du groupe harmonium avec lui
dans sa maison du lac saint jean les
confidences entre autres dans dorval de
luc picard et de france castel
l'entrevue avec michel côté a été filmé
un an avant son retrait de la vie
publique pour recevoir des traitements
contre une maladie de la moelle osseuse
je peux rien y faire
stoffer l'omerta comme
le recasement
mon père senghor de roberval qui était
adopté serge fiori a réalisé des
entretiens sans filtre et il a mis régis
labeaume à se confier comme jamais
auparavant je lui racontais mes échecs 1
je suis beaucoup parlé de ma vie
personnelle je suis allé très loin
parce que c'était pour serge et je me
suis surpris à
être comme dans mon salon en train de
prendre une bière avec mon mea mon
meilleur ami ou étaler tout ce monde qui
lors de ses rencontres serge fiori le
musicien n'est jamais loin de serge
fiori l'interviewer qui parfois
improvise peu chute de nous et ça ça
t'apprend une écoute ça vient ternir une
réponse le coup parce que
d'abord une multitude dans vos yeux
courtine lecoq me fous tu renvoies serge
fiori sera très occupé en 2022 en plus
des entrevues il ya aussi des concerts
d'harmonium symphonique et il doit
composer une grande marque et strahl
pour souligner le 100e anniversaire de
naissance de jean paul riopelle
ici oui je déprimais radio canada
montréal